bienvenidos de vuelta ahora vamos a
utilizar lo que hemos aprendido sobre el
concepto de trabajo y energía y todo lo
que hemos visto sobre la conservación de
la energía y vamos a aplicarlo a
máquinas sencillas y el primero de ellos
es la máquina que conocemos como la
palanca simple que tú puedes imaginarlo
como como estos juegos que puedes
encontrar en los parques como lo sube y
baja o bueno que son como balancines
digamos ok en este caso en este caso
podemos localizar un punto este punto de
aquí que es el que digamos balance a
toda esta tabla que podemos pensar que
es de madera digamos para fines de este
de este vídeo que es digamos para que
sea más sencillo vamos a suponer que
esta distancia es de un metro mientras
que el fulcro al punto final es de dos
metros ok entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es bueno aquí podemos podemos hacernos
muchas preguntas no por ejemplo
podríamos podríamos preguntarnos cuánta
fuerza hay que aplicar
cuanta fuerza hay que aplicar aquí para
que mantengamos el nivel verdad porque
este cuerpo que tenemos del otro lado
tiene un peso de 10 newton recordemos
que el peso es justo la fuerza que se
genera debido a la gravitación verdad y
si nosotros aplicamos una fuerza de este
otro lado podríamos preguntarnos cuánto
necesitamos para mantener esto
balanceado ok o todavía más por ejemplo
si nosotros aplicamos una fuerza cuanto
necesitamos aplicar para rotar esta
barra en sentido contrario a las
manecillas del reloj por ejemplo si
nosotros aplicamos una fuerza entonces
esta tabla va a moverse no sé quizás
algo así
que al aplicar una fuerza
se mueve más o menos
así muy bien
entonces lo que es importante es checar
que esta de este punto no se mueve
entonces esta distancia morada debe ser
igual a esta distancia amarilla en cada
uno de los lados verdad muy bien
entonces si uno aplica una fuerza y se
mueve digamos se desplaza esta esta
tabla con una con un ángulo teta
respecto a su posición original entonces
uno podría preguntarse cuánto subió este
objeto que estaba inicialmente aquí pero
que ahora tiene cierta altura de este
estilo esta altura digamos que esta
altura vamos a llamar la distancia no sé
debido al peso ya esta altura vamos a
llamarle distancia debido a la fuerza no
sé digamos por darle algún nombre
entonces nos podríamos preguntar cuánto
subió este cuerpo
de este lado o en real o por ejemplo
cuánto bajo la tabla de este otro lado
muy bien entonces ya que tenemos esta
imagen
11 simplemente utiliza funciones
trigonométricas para poder determinar
esta distancia verdad aquí tenemos justo
un ángulo recto y por supuesto cuando
elevamos esta tabla pues no queda
exactamente arriba de este de este punto
verdad sino que a lo mejor se mueve un
poco a la izquierda lo importante es que
esta distancia en amarillo también es de
1 metro y esta distancia es de 2 metros
muy bien entonces nosotros conocemos
esta distancia que es la hipotenusa y
queremos saber cuánto es esta distancia
que sería el cateto opuesto con respecto
a nuestro ángulo entonces unos
rápidamente recurren a las funciones
trigonométricas recordemos él
acá
tú a verdad con el soca todas podríamos
determinar cuál función trigonométricas
la relaciona el cateto opuesto con la
hipotenusa y eso es el seno de nuestro
ángulo verdad entonces lo que vamos a
tener es que el seno el seno de nuestro
ángulo será igual al cateto opuesto que
es la distancia del de vida al peso
dividido entre la hipotenusa que en este
caso es un metro muy bien ahora esto lo
podemos hacer exactamente igual con el
otro con el otro lado verdad porque
tenemos este mismo ángulo tenemos dos
rectas que se cruzan en un vértice los
ángulos opuestos son iguales entonces
nosotros podemos ver que el seno de este
ángulo el seno de este ángulo debe ser
igual al cateto puesto que es la de f
df
entre dos metros verdad entre la
hipotenusa porque aquí está nuestro
ángulo recto la hipotenusa sería este de
aquí que es dos metros muy bien entonces
con esto inmediatamente podríamos
determinar cómo están relacionadas estas
distancias y es que si nos damos cuenta
tenemos el mismo seno del ángulo que
iguala a estas dos cosas quiere decir
que entre ellas tienen que ser iguales
es decir esto de aquí que es la
distancia f entre 2 debe ser igual a la
distancia p entre un metro entonces la
distancia
efe sobre dos metros debe ser igual a la
distancia p
entre un metro entre
un metro entonces uno puede rápidamente
ver qué bueno a este uno no no tiene que
estar aquí bueno dividir entre uno da lo
mismo y podríamos ver que la distancia
efe es esencialmente 22 veces la
distancia p muy bien esto es lo que
hemos obtenido hasta este momento esta
distancia será el doble a la que
teníamos de este lado muy bien
ahora lo que sí sabemos es que tenemos
la ley de la conservación de la energía
entonces si nosotros aplicamos una
fuerza aquí esencialmente para poder ver
cuál fue la fuerza en realidad tenemos
que pensar que estamos imprimiendo la
energía a este sistema de nuestro sube y
baja y en realidad estamos transfiriendo
energía hasta el otro bloque hasta este
bloque azul que teníamos acá elevándolo
lo estamos elevando y así es como
estamos transfiriendo la energía a este
bloque entonces lo que vamos a tener es
lo siguiente tenemos esta fuerza esta
fuerza f
efe es igual a pero no no no es igual
sino que si nosotros aplicamos esta
fuerza y recorrimos esta distancia esto
es en realidad el trabajo generado por
esta fuerza y por la ley de la
conservación de la energía debe ser
igual al trabajo que se genera del otro
lado ahora aquí tú dirás dónde está la
fuerza pues la fuerza está en este
bloque que dijimos que le imprime una
fuerza de 10
entonces porque ese es su peso entonces
vamos a tener 10 newtons 10 newtons por
la distancia que s
que se desplazó que es de p dt
muy bien entonces ahora podríamos
utilizar esta ecuación que ya obtuvimos
donde df es dos veces de pe y entonces
tendremos que la fuerza es esfuerza por
fuerza por de f que dijimos que era dos
veces de pe dos veces de pe debe ser
igual a diez newtons 10 newtons por bp
entonces podemos dividir de ambos lados
entre dos de pp y que es lo que nos
queda que nuestra fuerza nuestra fuerza
es igual a 10 newtons entre 2 que serían
5 newtons y luego de p / de p es una
verdad entonces esto es lo que hemos
obtenido que nuestra fuerza es de 5
minutos y esto es muy interesante porque
si te fijas muy bien lo que pasó es que
multiplicamos la fuerza verdad en
realidad esta fuerza era de 10 minutos y
sólo tuvimos que aplicar 5 entonces al
aplicar 5 newtons obtuvimos una fuerza
de 10
pero qué fue lo que pasó que en realidad
yo tenía que aplicarlo al doble de
distancia de lo que fue aquí verdad
quedamos que esta distancia de efe era
el doble de la distancia de p entonces
mientras que aplique la mitad de la
fuerza tuve que recorrer el doble de
distancia para poder elevar este peso de
10 minutos y tú a lo mejor ya estarás
pensando que esto puede pasar en general
y de hecho si por eso es que tiene mucho
sentido definir esto que es la ventaja
mecánica como la proporción la
proporción entre los digamos
o bueno más bien es la proporción que
hay entre la fuerza de entrada perdón la
fuerza de salida entre la fuerza de
entrada y esto es lo que definimos como
la ventaja mecánica y ya estarás
pensando que la ventaja mecánica en
realidad puede ser la proporción entre
las longitudes que había de que define
este fulcro verdad el fulcro define
estas dos distancias y a lo mejor la
ventaja mecánica es la proporción entre
esas longitudes verdad entonces uno en
realidad puede hacerlo más un poquito
más en general
digamos que que tenemos nuevamente
nuestro nuestro sube y baja aquí o que
quizás debería hacerlo un poco más
derechito
más derechito
ok ahí tenemos nuestro balancín digamos
aquí tenemos el fulcro verdad y aquí
digamos que tengo una distancia de 1 y
aquí una distancia de 2 además si yo
aplico una fuerza f1 aquí y una fuerza
hacia abajo efe 2 y entonces lo que
vamos a tener en general es que f 2 x de
ya te lo estás imaginando tiene que ser
f1 por de 1 verdad yo no podría pensar
más o menos como que esto es el trabajo
pero no no es exactamente así porque el
trabajo sería la fuerza 2 por la
distancia que se desplazó de esta sería
la distancia verdad pero pero tienen
están están relacionados porque nosotros
sabemos o ya vimos en un ejemplo que de
sobre la altura digamos esta altura que
se desplazó h 2 verdad es este es igual
a de 1 entre la h 1 que sería la altura
que se desplazó hacia arriba entonces si
uno sustituye de dos aquí tendríamos
algo así como f dos por de dos que en
este caso sería de 1 por h 2 entre h 1 y
esto sería igual a f 1 por de 1 si
nosotros cancelamos los de unos
tendríamos efe 2 por h 2 que sería
justamente el trabajo y el h 1 si lo
pasamos aquí multiplicando tendríamos f1
por h1 que sería también el trabajo
entonces realmente estamos hablando de
la conservación de la energía ok
entonces esta ecuación de aquí que
acabamos de pintar esta ecuación de aquí
esta de aquí es esencialmente lo que
tienes que conocer muy bien ya está a
esto
a esta cantidad que tenemos de este lado
es lo que conocemos como el
muy bien entonces en próximos vídeos
utilizaré estas cantidades para resolver
un montón de problemas sobre ventaja
mecánica nos vemos pronto